KATIE PAVLICH.
"THE FIVE"."
SO WHO KNEW THAT CALLING THE
COPS WHEN YOUR FAMILY IS
THREATENED COMES FROM A PLACE OF
PRIVILEGE?
>> WHAT IF IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT MY HOME IS BROKEN INTO?
WHO DO I CALL?
>> YES, I MEAN, I HEAR THAT LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM A LOT OF MY
NEIGHBORS AND I KNOW, AND MYSELF
AND I KNOW THAT THAT COMES FROM
A PLACE OF PRIVILEGE.
>> Greg: WHAT AN IDIOT.
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
MINNEAPOLIS CITY COUNCIL WHO IS
PLANNING A FORMAL VOTE TO DEFUND
THE POLICE.
SO AFTER DAYS OF UNREST, THAT IS
THEIR NEXT STEP.
IF YOU DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE
ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A MASS
DELUSION WHERE HUMANITY IS
WILLFULLY REJECTING WHAT WORKS
FOR WHAT DESTROYS, I DON’T THINK
I CAN HELP YOU.
BUT IF YOU CAN’T BEAT THE MOB,
WHY NOT HELP THEM?
LET’S DEFUND.
BABY STEPS FIRST, IT’S TOO
EXPENSIVE TO START FROM SCRATCH
AND CREATE A POLICE FREE CITY,
SO LET’S PICK TWO CITIES AND
OBSERVE THE OUTCOMES.
BECAUSE THE MINNEAPOLIS
CITY COUNCIL IS VOTING TO
DEFUND, LET’S GO WITH THEM FIRST
AND LET’S DO HOLLYWOOD WHERE
SOME CELEBS WHO SIGNED AN OPEN
LETTER DEMANDING FUNDING
ACTUALLY LIVED.
THE COMPARISON ELIMINATES RAYS
FROM THE EQUATION AND SITS IT
SQUARELY ON SOMETHING ELSE.
WEALTH AND CLASS.
WHILE CITIZENS OF MINNEAPOLIS
WILL FALL PREY TO CHAOS AND
ROVING GANGS OF VIOLENCE, LAST
WEEK BEING THE PREQUEL,
HOLLYWOOD WILL RELY ON PRIVATE
SECURITY, WHICH MANY OF ITS
FABULOUS INHABITANTS ALREADY
ENJOY.
IT’S WHY JOHN LEGEND AND OTHERS
SEE NO PROBLEM IN DEFUNDING,
BECAUSE IT WILL BE A PROBLEM FOR
THEM.
AT LEAST WITH MINNEAPOLIS, THE
HARD LEFT ZOMBIES ON THE COUNCIL
ARE READY TO SEE THEIR DELUSION
THROUGH.
CITIZENS BE OR KILLED.
LET’S SEE HOLLYWOOD SEE THE SAME
THING.
WHILE THE RICH DO FINE WHILE THE
POOR SUFFER MAYBE THAT INJUSTICE
WILL BE TELEVISED TOO, IN COLOR,
NOT JUST BLACK AND WHITE.
SO DANA, HERE IS A QUESTION.
IF WE CAN DEFUND THE POLICE
WHICH WE USED TO BELIEVE THEY
WERE ESSENTIAL TO GOVERNANCE,
WHY CAN’T THE ENTIRE GOVERNMENT
TO BE DEFUNDED?
WHAT’S MORE ESSENTIAL THAN THE
POLICE?
IT’S NOT SENATORS, IT’S NOT
CONGRESSMEN.
WHY NOT ACROSS THE BOARD?
>> Dana: REMEMBER BACK IN
JUNIOR HIGH, BACK IN OUR DAY,
YOU LEARNED THE HIERARCHY OF
NEEDS.
WHAT’S THE VERY FIRST NEED?
ON WHICH EVERYTHING ELSE
DEPENDS?
SECURITY.
SO THERE IS ONE THING THAT WE
ALL LEARNED, PROBABLY LEARNED IN
KINDERGARTEN.
THE OTHER THING IS, MINNEAPOLIS
HAS SAID IT NEEDS ABOUT
$45 MILLION.
THEY ARE ASKING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR HELP TO DEAL WITH
HOW THE DAMAGE THAT HAPPENS.
WHY SHOULD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDE MINNEAPOLIS
WITH THAT KIND OF SUPPORT IF
THEY’RE GOING TO TRY THIS
EXPERIMENT OF DISMANTLING THE
POLICE?
I THINK THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD PROBABLY WAIT
ON THAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT I THOUGHT
WAS PRETTY INTERESTING, YOU SEE
THAT SOME IN THE MEDIA ARE
ALREADY TRYING TO HELP THE LEFT
DEAL WITH THIS DEFUND THE POLICE
SLOGAN.
SAYING IT NEEDS MORE CONTEXT,
DOESN’T MEAN THAT.
WHERE WE SEEN IT BEFORE?
IT’S LIKE WHEN THEY PUT OUT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL AND IT WAS LIKE
THEY WANT TO DO WHAT?
ACTUALLY, NO.
WHAT IT REALLY MEANS IS, JUST
GOING TO TINKER AROUND THE
EDGES.
WHAT ABOUT "BELIEVE ALL WOMEN"?
NO, WE DON’T DO THAT EITHER.
WHAT WAS THE OTHER ONE?
BAN CORPORATE MONEY FROM
CAMPAIGNS?
AND YET THEY ALL TAKE THE
CORPORATE MONEY.
AT SOME POINT THE PROGRESSIVE
LEFT IS GOING TO FIGURE OUT THE
ESTABLISHMENT DEMOCRATS ARE JUST
IGNORING ALL OF THEIR SLOGANS
PARTLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
NONSENSICAL BUT ALSO BECAUSE
THEY DON’T BELIEVE THEM.
>> Greg: RIGHT TO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS, JOHN OLIVER
HAS BECOME THE SPOKESPERSON FOR
THE CATHEDRAL.
HE’S THE ONE THAT’S NOW
EXPLAINING ALL OF THESE ISSUES
IS NOT REALLY BEING WHAT THEY
ARE.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR "DEFUND THE
POLICE," WHICH SOUNDS
UNREASONABLE AND STUPID.
THEN THEY RETREAT TO A POSITION
THAT SOUNDS REASONABLE BY
COMPARISON.
IT’S A SNEAKY STRATEGY.
WE DON’T MEAN THAT.
WE MEAN SHIFTING INTO YOUTH AT
RISK.
JUST SHIFTING FUNDS AROUND.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THEY ORIGINALLY
SAID.
THEY ARE DOING THIS BY COVER.
AND I KNOW YOU AGREE.
JUAN NOW.
I WAS THINKING TO MYSELF WAIT A
MINUTE.
SOMETHING LIKE, I THINK BY THE
WAY, DEFUND THE POLICE MAKES NO
SENSE TO ME.
I REJECT THAT OUT OF HAND.
BUT I HEAR THE SLOGAN.
I HEAR THE SLOGAN, MUCH LIKE I
HEAR THE SLOGAN, YOU KNOW, BUILD
THE WALL, DRAIN THE SWAMP ON THE
RIGHT.
IT STIRS UP THE RIGHT WING BASE.
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IT
STIRS UP SOME IN THE POLITICAL
EXTREME.
OKAY.
TO ME, IT’S A NONSTARTER.
THANK YOU, JESSE.
I HOPE YOU BELIEVE THAT.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THERE ARE
REFORMS.
>> Jesse: I CAN SEE WITH MY
OWN EYES.
>> Juan: I SEE IT TOO.
I CAN SEE RIGHT THROUGH IT, IN
FACT.
BUT I THINK THAT WE CAN EMBRACE
AND YOU KNOW, IT’S NOW NOT JUST
FAR LEFT.
IT’S LIKE 60% OF AMERICANS SAY
THAT THE POLICE USED EXCESSIVE
FORCE IN DEALING WITH BLACK
AMERICANS.
YOU HEAR A VERY CONSERVATIVE
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM SAY THERE
IS PROBLEM HERE.
AND SO IN THIS CONGRESSIONAL
BILL THAT WAS PUT FORWARD TODAY,
YOU SEE SOME REALISTIC REFORMS
THAT ARE EMBRACED OR CAN BE
EMBRACED BY THE LIKES OF ME
ANYWAY, THINGS LIKE BANS ON
CHOKE HOLD, INCREASED USE OF THE
BODY CAMERAS AND THE LIKES.
NO MORE NO KNOCK WARRANTS LIKE
WHAT RESULTED IN THE DEATH OF
BREONNA TAYLOR.
THESE ARE LOGICAL AND GOOD
STEPS.
THE IDEA THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
MORE OFFICERS TAKEN AWAY FROM
DEALING WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MENTAL ISSUES OR DRUG PROBLEMS
OR YOUTH THAT NEED HELP.
IT SEEMS TO ME THOSE ARE
RATIONAL, GOOD STEPS FOR AMERICA
TO TAKE.
>> Greg: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS
IS THAT NOBODY’S ACTUALLY
HELPING THE MENTALLY ILL, AT
LEAST IN OUR CITIES.
POLICE ARE OFTEN LEFT WITH THAT
BURDEN.
I WOULD LIKE IT SHIFTED TO
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS BUT
THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
KATIE --
>> Juan: WE AGREE.
>> Greg: THE UPSIDE, KATIE,
YOU KNOW THERE’S AN UPSIDE.
THE PRIVATIZATION.
THE FACT THAT WE CAN ROLL THAT
GUN CONTROL LAWS BECAUSE OF WE
ARE NO LONGER BEING PROTECTED,
WE’VE GOT TO PROTECT OURSELVES.
>> Katie: GREG, DOESN’T THAT
REALLY EXPOSE THE WAY THAT THEY
OPERATE?
IT’S SO ILLOGICAL.
FIRST THEY ADVOCATE FOR GUN
CONTROL SO THAT YOU CAN’T DEFEND
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU NEED TO CALL
THE POLICE.
THEN THEY FARMED YOU.
THEY THEN GET RID OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND SAY THAT YOU ARE
ON YOUR OWN AND IF YOU CALL THE
POLICE, IT’S PART OF YOUR WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
THEREFORE YOU ESSENTIALLY
DESERVE WHATEVER WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO YOU IF SOMEONE BROKE
INTO YOUR HOUSE LATE AT NIGHT.
THAT’S THE FIRST PROBLEM.
I HAVE SOME LONGTIME FRIENDS,
THEY HAVE A SHOW IN MINNEAPOLIS,
LOCAL RADIO SHOW.
THEY CALL IT THE MINNESOTA CITY
CLOWN-CIL.
IT’S NOT ABOUT JUSTICE.
IT’S ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
THIS MEANS.
POLICE ARE THERE TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS THAT ARE PASSED BY
REPRESENTATIVES, WHETHER IT’S
THE STATE LEVEL OR THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
THOSE REPRESENTATIVES ARE VOTED
INTO OFFICE BY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, BY CITIZENS WHO CHOOSE
WHO THEIR LEADERS ARE TO PUT
THOSE LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE POLICE
ENFORCING THE LAWS, THEN
EVERYTHING IS UP FOR GRABS IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE’S FEELINGS,
WHAT’S JUSTICE BASED ON SKIN
COLOR AND CLASS, NOBODY’S
ACTUALLY EQUAL UNDER THE LAW
ANYMORE.
SO THIS IS A BIGGER QUESTION OF
WHAT IS THE END GOAL HERE OF
TEARING DOWN THE ENTIRE SYSTEM,
NOT JUST "DEFUNDING" THE POLICE
WERE IMPLEMENTING SOME KIND OF
REFORM.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE POLICE
ENFORCING THE LAWS MADE BY THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PEOPLE,
EVERYTHING STARTS TO BREAK DOWN.
>> Greg: IT’S NO SURPRISE THAT
IT IS THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
GOVERNMENT THAT ONLY HE IS
DEALING WITH ONE HALF OF THE
EQUATION, THE POLICE.
THEY ARE GOING TO SOLVE THE
POLICE PROBLEM BUT NOT THE
CRIMINAL PROBLEM.
THEY DON’T SEE THAT IF YOU JUST
REMOVE THAT, THE CRIMINAL
PROBLEM ACTUALLY GETS WORSE.
>> Jesse: YEAH, EVERYBODY SEES
THAT EXCEPT -- I WON’T NAME
NAMES, BUT JUST TO MENTION
SOMETHING JUAN BROUGHT UP.
450 MILES OF THE BORDER WALL HAS
BEEN BUILT ACCORDING TO
POLITICO, MR. WILLIAMS.
YES, THE SWAP IS BEING DRAINED.
THAT’S WHY JAMES COMEY AND HIS
MERRY BAND OF MISWITS GOT FIRED.
>> Juan: YOU ARE BACK ON YOUR
HEELS.
>> Jesse: THIS MIGHT BE THE
DUMBEST.
TAKE A POSITION THAT THE WHOLE
COUNTRY AGREES WITH, THAT THE
DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD WAS A
HORRIBLE THING, AND THEN DO
THREE SOMERSAULTS BACKWARDS INTO
A POSITION THAT 90% OF THE
COUNTRY DISAGREES WITH.
DEFUND THE POLICE.
DANA IS RIGHT.
THEY DID IT WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT.
EVERYBODY WANTS CLEAN AIR AND
WATER THAT THEY SAY LET’S SPEND
100 TRILLION AND BAN AIRPLANES.
THEY DID IT, THEY’VE DONE IT
WITH EVERYTHING.
SO IF YOU TAKE AWAY THE POLICE,
WHO IS GOING TO PROTECT THE
CITY’S?
THE GUYS WITH THE GUNS.
WHO HAS THE GUNS?
THE GANGS HAVE THE GUNS.
NOW YOU HAVE TO PAY A FEE FOR A
GAME TO PROTECT YOU.
IT’S CALLED A PROTECTION RACKET.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE CALLING
THE POLICE WHEN THEIR HOME WAS
BURGLARIZED, WHO ARE THEY GOING
TO SEND?
NOT A POLICE OFFICER.
THEY ARE SENDING A SOCIAL
WORKER.
THAT’S IN THE FINE PRINT OF THIS
DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT,
WHATEVER THAT’S GOING TO DO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLICE IN
TERMS OF THESE INNER CITIES, A
MAJORITY OF THE POLICE OFFICERS
ARE ACTUALLY BLACK AND A LOT OF
THESE BIG CITIES AND A LOT OF
THE POLICE CHIEFS IN THESE
CITIES ARE BLACK TOO.
WHERE DO THE UNION DUES GO FROM
THE POLICE UNIONS?
THEY GO TO DEMOCRATS.
SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE JUST
HURTING THEMSELVES WITH THIS,
POLITICALLY AND IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
IF THEY WANT TO GO, LET THEM DO
IT.
EVERYONE IS JUST GOING TO FLEE
THE CITIES AND BY GUNS.
THE TWO THINGS DEMOCRATS SAY
THEY DON’T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
>> Dana: GREG, I KNOW YOU HAVE
A TEASE.
CAN I MAKE A POINT?
>> Greg: SURE.
>> Dana: I JUST WANTED TO
REMIND EVERYBODY.
IN NEW YORK CITY,
MAYOR de BLASIO IS SAYING THAT
HE IS GOING TO REDUCE FUNDING
FOR THE POLICE, AND HE WANTS TO
PUT IT INTO MORE THINGS LIKE
EDUCATION AND DEALING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH.
BUT IF YOU’LL REMEMBER, IT WAS
ACTUALLY THE NEW YORK CITY
GOVERNMENT ITSELF THAT HAD TO
ADMIT THAT de BLASIO’S
EDUCATION PROGRAM OF WHICH THEY
SPENT ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS.
THEY CAN’T FIGURE OUT ANY
PROGRAM THAT ACTUALLY WAS
BENEFITED FROM THAT OR DID
BETTER AND ALSO WHEN HIS WIFE
DID ALL THAT WORK ON MENTAL
HEALTH, THEY HAD TO ADMIT THAT
THEY BASICALLY WASTED A BILLION
DOLLARS ON THAT TOO.
I’M NOT SURE IF NEW YORK SHOULD
FALL FOR THAT.
>> Greg: I THINK HE’S GOING TO
KEEP THE POLICE DETAIL WHEN HE